man who needs some attention
man is he snow is starved for some air
time had it all Adam Sandler playing
hurt by your gritty and gutting I got
have the voice of a true man
today Yeah right it sounds cool you
sound like Demi Moore uh so there's a
lot of things to get to today with you
first of all the Hawaii Coast was great
yeah what you kept trying to come in
Wally
I know but why you wanted it so cool he
never talks to me and I knew on air he
had to at least I noticed when the
camera went off and he did not talk to
you looked the other way
well he's always nice to me with his
wife he they come over and I've been to
that restaurant you know that he goes to
yeah I've been in maybe five times day
eight times and every time I was there
and Al and his wife come over to the
table and then amazing how do what's the
best way to approach you when you're
having dinner anyway with your family
yeah and somebody wants to because they
always say I don't mean to interrupt
we're sorry to bother right so how does
it work where you don't get angry I
never get idea I go hey you want to do
it after we eat and then they go but
we're done usually I would happen would
you stand up and then no no I oh come on
because okay it'll eat up then that's
announcing out in the restaurant let's
do this man
I go come here come here let's like
pretend we're hanging out sort of like
you announcing yourself by coming in and
interrupting Al Michaels know whatever
interruption I don't like you back oh is
that what it was I gave you a big laugh
man I gave you a big laugh when's the
last time you asked for a picture with
the celebrity ah man that's a good
question I think it's happened they she
I don't remember I get I do that with
sports guys I go like who Scottie Pippen
maybe two years ago I saw Scottie Pippen
as a hey I got a do this yeah guys guys
I I love what about Jordan boy I screwed
up he hosted Saturday Night Live I was
with him a whole week and it was nuts
I remember when Jordan hosted SNL
Lauren was telling everybody just stop
with the autograph stop leave alone and
I remember she nighter
C insider with a basketball I saw we're
not allowed to do that he's like hey
George I got everybody got to get their
autograph and you were the one that
didn't get it on now I regret it how
good was Jordan on Saturday night one
was we all were in love with him he was
the greatest hung out with a flap like
the Jordan you love uh you know on the
when he hits a shot in smiles that's who
we had on on the show he was hanging out
we became tight with for the week and
then he want to be great like you could
see what makes him great as a basketball
player did he apply that same I don't
think he had that much pressure on
himself because he is genuinely lovable
and he wanted it he wanted to do it
right for the show's sake I don't think
he was like I want to be a great host
but he was he was just cool man handsome
dude just great great just own the whole
place it was the most you stared at
somebody wherever he went
hit me Springsteen Springsteen when he
did the show too is very much like that
but you do a Springsteen impersonation I
could do them right now pretty good okay
with this voice yeah you want to hear
yeah hey baby
that doesn't fritzy doesn't like
Springsteen I feel like Spurs okay I
don't like nice extremely overrated okay
but he likes him you think is really
overrated guys give Sandman your
Springsteen meddling all right come on
now masters a participant a club cover
down hey little girl daddy daddy boom
mas que salen
already yeah we just get to I gotta say
seeing Springsteen is a your home live
I've never said well there you go
so Billy Joel a bunch of times that's a
great one game is your scene when you
see Springsteen is it the same way with
Jordan that kind of look don't touch and
no no no both of those guys were
friendly eight like we hung you couldn't
get pictures buddy we did a skit with
Jordan where we were like a I was like a
Globetrotter skit right I don't remember
the whole thing but we shot at a YMCA in
New York City with Jordan and we were on
the same team as him when we got to pass
him the ball and he'd take a shot and he
was in a wig though right he had some
old at work yeah yeah but but it was it
was he was just cool and laughs what's
his character was that the one where
he's motorboat Jones or hey BAE maybe
yeah he's doing like a spoof or you had
a way back that sweet river Baynes
that's what it was yeah promotable now
the difference is that bank closed I
think paulie's revealing something about
his home life motorboat the Sandman is
here - these guys um for some reason we
keep coming back to this where we we
hear snippets of when you audition for
sad night log what did you do crazy
stuff when you audition for Saturday I
know you didn't do something I didn't
have any weird voices to do I didn't
have nothing I just did stand-up I did
stand-up in the at the Chicago improv
but when you finished yeah what did you
think I didn't get it
so I thought I wasn't I kept going on
man these episodes cocky I was like
those guys are gonna blow it you're not
gonna get me and that's all it was on
them what's in your hand oh wow those
guys who did the show and the sandwich
right here they don't even know it how
funny did you think you were back then I
thought I didn't think I was the
funniest guy I just thought I was meant
for that show and I was I just thought I
was ready to pop I was ready to do
something I don't know why I thought I
was so great what were you going to do
if that didn't like geela back I'm
really zero even thought that I wasn't
gonna pop I don't I was psychotic I
think like you knew we that this was
going to happen
my brother said to me when I was 17 I
said what do I want to do
when I was filling up my college
applications what should i what major
should I do he goes wanted to be an
actor I said yeah yeah yeah he goes be a
comedian you're you're as funny as Eddie
Murphy I go yeah that's what I was like
that I go yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're right I get how much fun is that
okay I'll do that
who did you look up to as a meeting
comedian I loved I love Rodney I loved
Eddie what was Rodney Dangerfield like
being around he was oh he was as rowdy
as you would think but later in his
light anywhere bathro but nothing
underneath a lot of time yeah which is
funny but I don't know if he was trying
to be funny I don't know I he was a good
dude like when you wish I ate I remember
eating lunch would Ronnie during Little
Nicky it was just me and Ronnie sitting
in my trailer and just talking relaxed
and he was just a sweet guy just a sweet
guy with he did have he did feel like he
he wasn't like in no respect about from
the industry he just felt like he was no
respect guy in life is just all this
this is this he felt like he always had
bad luck in all those stories and then
but he was a genuine sweet guy I do
remember when the Hanukkah song I don't
know why would you you how many times
have I asked you in lieu of getting paid
to be in your movies I said would you
come on the show and do Happy Hanukkah
the hanukkah's yeah yeah and you refused
to do it if you don't just dude on it
why you just don't you don't bring that
one out that's like asking Elvis come on
man jailhouse rock jail out throg right
now you know you know but I was asking
for fritzy and McLovin who are Jewish
they hear they've heard it before they
don't need it live man hmm
Rodney anyways Ronnie didn't Rodney said
to me boys he goes uh what are you doing
they're announcing everybody you're a
Jew yeah like I know you know I guess I
wouldn't tell I know I just let it if
they know they know but
was i selling it did you hear from
anybody that you name dropped in the
hanukkah zone like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you you I got a few uh or were
there people saying why did you leave me
out of the Hanukkah song yeah sometimes
I've heard that I go well you're too
obvious everybody knows your G but you
got in Rod Carew that was a great 1/2 oh
my god when I was a kid and I saw Rod
Carew with that I think yeah hi necklace
on my god was that a big day for me even
though he he was convert he converted to
Jenny buddy was cool with the Jews I was
like let's go but do you do what these
guys do fritzy McLovin will look at
somebody like Josh Rosen at UCLA right
so they're like this I you know we can't
wait for this yes mclubbe okay exactly
Avene for the Minnesota Timberwolves
yeah every vijaya shouting name that's
good exactly we want to claim somebody
yeah hi next time when we found out that
he wasn't doing matter we looked the
other way on those hands not along this
by the way ya know if you guys could
have acquired Herschel Walker they
woulda been a great ha ha ha that's good
yeah has she how many pushups you gonna
do a show stop when you squat the movie
is sandy Wexler where a Sandman is a
talent manager working in Los Angeles in
the 1990s yes I've been around sandy if
you had I had been runnin here yes he
has he is a real person there but he's a
fascinating guy because he used to
represent Evel Knievel right I mean he
did he did a lot of things back in the
70s yeah you know all those stories then
he represent the people of the cast from
friends oh yeah yeah that's the big
thing he says so you know how much money
I got the people from friend million and
every yeah he did he did he but come on
the Evel Knievel stuff is great yeah he
tells those stories about Evel Knievel
why did you he's had a lot of greats he
had yeah he said you know he did them
sadly he I think he did the deal for
Saturday Night Live the first Lawrence
deal like at the beginning and he's your
agent he's my manager yes
your men's he's my what is he do by the
one he's oh he just all day long
dealing with them asking questions about
me and sending scripts and making sure
life goes smooth for me but most of the
time he just handles me yelling at him
on the phone because I've seen him I
never knew what he did yeah he says he
does what I just said but I asked he's a
good the movie is a sandy Wexler yeah
Netflix Danny now available you were
going to be in it that was I love the
Olympics how to do the Olympic on the
way but there's a movie and a movie
offer yeah that is coming up here after
the break right see that's a cheese
that's easy this way you do like Ryan
Seacrest does system that's right after
the break right so Sandman has a movie
offer for me after the break Dan Patrick
the movie is sandy Wexler the next
Netflix it's available now on Netflix so
you had but do-over ridiculous six
blended grownups too well the Netflix
deal it was to do over ridiculous six +
NS auntie Wexler self in Sandy Wexler I
have to go five to go five to five more
to go in then that's it
well that's but now you never know what
are you gonna do when you're older are
you gonna so you might start a lot of
retired a fifty for that that's what I
was thinking
54 yeah but every time I say I'm gonna
retire my kids go
you'll be home oh yeah is that bad yeah
daddy but as a comedian yeah you
wouldn't retire I can do stand-up my
whole life I don't know about we'll see
we'll see I don't know what that one's
supposed to do I bet you you like doing
it every day yeah it's fun I asked you I
think I keep going but you be bored if
you can't you at home right like you
know at home yeah yeah you don't do
anything or like you don't have a hobby
I bat basketball yeah that's an hour
yeah and then it's all good
well I'm sorely come home and got that
big house and you're all alone oh you
know what it's either Jacuzzi or pool
that's my big decision I don't know
maybe the pool today
I do do laundry when it happens it's
awesome usually when I visit New
Hampshire III feel guilty with my mom my
mother has to see my underwear let me
get bug on that's the only thing you'll
do is you're unaware let me mom not you
do - you do it a shirt so I got the
other way when you get redo read reviews
no even when they call me up and say so
so said a good thing I'm like I don't
care man he he said 40 bad things about
that but when did you get - you had to
have people complimented you not it
earlier in your career you mean in the
press yeah I don't know now I pretty
quick they went against me that's why I
stopped reading it it wasn't Billy
Madison that Hayes land and I didn't
expect and I thought oh these guys are
going to see I'm trying to do something
I don't know connecting to my generation
bubble buck and then I read all how bad
it was I thought oh my god I didn't know
they were gonna hate hate this but happy
gilmore same thing that he hated it how
do you how do you hate happy gilmore I I
don't know I know but it doesn't matter
I keep going and then I'm not thinking
that unless III every time I do a movie
like the director or somebody new one
it's got Sandman reviews can be good and
it I'm like nothing it not there don't
even think about you know it's not going
to be good it's gonna hate and even if
it is good you don't care even if it's
good I can't accept a good good one one
at ten before were so nasty and we're
not on the same we're not connecting me
in those guys wouldn't hold is your
sense of humor like it like what age
like you are you a 15 year old or 20
like where is your sense of humor I
don't know right this this new one mean
smile of putting together in early and
Chris Rock it seems a little more I'm
playing an older guy because I haven't
thought I'm doing a movie would rock
with that my my daughter's going to
marry
son so I guess I'm playing an older guy
in that one and uh and the the humor I
don't know I always go for everybody I
in the beginning I was talking just to
my age or a little younger and now I I
try to include everybody what's the last
movie you saw not yours that you went
Wow oh I just I don't know I watched it
Bowie documentary the other night I like
that I like me
did you watch Long Island and I think
that movie was awesome yeah I didn't see
it for a long time and then I saw it in
my hotel like two weeks ago and I
couldn't really about great it was I
loved it so you're in and I I'm not in
the know man I don't when everybody's
getting nominated and everybody's
talking about who's the greatest this
year I never know what to talk about I
never go to I never see any movies at
the time and I don't put them in there
during that you know when we get all the
DVD and stuff I don't I don't watch him
then either I hang out with and do my
own thing mostly and then like a couple
years later I see it and I go oh that's
why that's why it was all nuts for that
no but that la la man that was
incredible I loved what TV shows you
want I don't do my I just watch sports
like I just watched playoffs last night
NBA Playoffs I watch I watch every
Yankee game I'd say about 90% of them I
skip some innings because my kids think
I'm you know I got a deal with life
thing but uh but I love the Yankees this
year my god it's fun would you want to
own a sports team I think of that
sometimes like when Jeter's you know
doing a stuff I stopped during the act
could be cool and then I I'm such a it's
funny like I meet these guys and and
then I don't like I don't know I don't I
don't I don't want to root against
anybody I don't want to I know if I own
a team I'd be full banana what if you
let let's say hypothetically you could
be part owner of the Red Sox I couldn't
do it because you're Yankee fan yeah I
couldn't and they wouldn't want me how'd
you become a Yankee fan growing up in
new hive sure Mike from New York and my
father
it was a Yankee fan Oh chuckling in yeah
and you go to Yankee Stadium you throw
it first pitch and all those I'm
shooting a movie in Long Island this
summer so I get to go to Yankee games
all summer yes I'm going to ask I'm
gonna call them and ask if I get your
auto fixed so there's you're gonna call
it and I'm going to ask get me in there
man I want to get out there again and
you've done that before them to a pitch
with Chris Rock one time yeah but Ron
can't throw he didn't throw well that
seemed like the next day like that he
had it off hey you missed a piece he had
an off day yesterday how do you still
sleep yeah even Rock mister start right
after that yeah you have a movie offer
for me is this an official presentation
of a movie on for this summer can you
play Irish can you play and play Irish
and you play East Coast Irish with it I
gotta go accent again no no you gotta be
it's gonna be in your accent now you did
this to me with Zohan where you want me
to play a Middle East you said can I can
you do a Middle East accent let's hear
it can you I didn't think of it alright
but if were you messing with me because
I was I felt like Rob Schneider got that
role as the taxi driver be honest with
me did Schneider get that role instead
of me yes okay yeah all right so I just
have to be Irish this summer I think you
just got to look like you we're gonna
get it done am i a bartender but we're
working on it all we're working on the
details we're gonna get it all straight
and it's going to be a great time I
can't give you everything yet but you
said if but I want you then we're gonna
have fun it's going to be no trip for
you like usually you got a fly yeah
hours and hours yeah and I want that but
want to get the boys in it too so whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
I don't want them to have to fly I want
them to have a nice afternoon on the set
of a Sandler movie oh so you're just
inviting them to the movie no I want him
in it I wouldn't just do that one
wanting to watch it you just said they
weren't Jewish enough to be in the movie
what happen they won me over something
about yes well how offer accepted on
behalf of want to run it past anybody I
pleasure
that's not scale what they have been
extended the offer if you did
extend the offer to me it's a it is it a
package deal
the the love I have for all of all five
of you guys is the same it is yeah yeah
but I've done a ton of stuff for you but
like I don't know y'all but I guarantee
when you hang out the following that you
look at them you go should I and they go
yeah yeah get it over there we'll
continue with the Sandman your voices
sound a little bit better stronger yeah
your bring it out you're getting bring
it yeah
sandy Wexler's the movie it's available
right now on Netflix along with the
do-over ridiculous six yes um
house drew Barrymore doing so good yeah
I was doing great yeah drew Julie and I
co-starred in blended I miss I miss
Africa I thought of that this morning
yeah yeah yeah I didn't make think I
think no I didn't you would have liked
did you get recognized in something yeah
yeah pretty funny yeah yes absolutely
what do they ask you in South Africa on
the street what's the matter with your
head why does it look like that okay so
the same things I would ask your
daughter was fantastic and blended by oh
that's right
yes blossomed into a young beauty too
and I like the boyfriend dana point own
yeah yeah
respect intimidate him a little bit he
knows because you got daughters oh yeah
yeah but he seems like a gentleman
that's I know but what's gonna happen
when guys come over and they I don't
think I'm gonna handle look I'm not
gonna be good you're solid right yeah I
can't handle it I get Man III but I
trust my daughters
oh yeah I trust that so but it just feel
what I feel like that they're not loving
they they're allowing their feelings for
somebody else that doesn't hurt well
they she still loves me more than she
loves him oh good yes I mean oh is that
yes absolutely but your daughters I
think you you'll hire somebody to be the
enforcer I think it'll be me I'm telling
I got a crazy temper with I think those
guys are in trouble those guys are in
trouble over comes over that sounds like
a movie okay yeah it could be a funny
movie or very sad yes
we put a kick daddy
it's called daddy sock next on Netflix
stop daddy stop
daddy will continue with Adam Sandler
right after this magic show what car did
you like today I got the Kevin James
Cadillac II the one he bought me one but
I do have a new challenge Mike Kevin
James monkey you were gone me a car to
be nice because I threw out the
Maseratis to everybody so he got me a
caddy so did Kevin James get a Maserati
yeah Chris Rock got a Maserati yes
Rob Schneider got a Maserati got an
electric car he got the test Tesla yeah
Spade gotta pay got the Maserati yeah
and you got what I didn't get diddly you
a century this is the compression damn
we're getting mopeds but its tricked-out
go three on the tree yeah that's like it
for more information visit Continental
Tire calm got no time for what you do
multiple reports here Tony Parker is
done for the season arable season-ending
surgery and if you watch that injury
like it didn't look like it was one of
those yeah any and come now weird it
just went out on ya so he's uh he's done
worst injury you ever had
well he was oh my worst yeah uh you know
I broke a lot of bones broke a lot of
bones I playing basketball broke my
ankle playing basketball slip on a corn
on a knee corn yes
nobody sweeps off your driveway my more
I played with my nephew Tyler yeah I
stepped on a course slid fell to break
try to continue play because I said I
kept saying I don't have enough time to
have a lot of time I was shooting a
movie shooting bedtime stories broke my
ankle in middle of that and then I had
to hop around everything I saw were you
playing a Duke you're going with Luke
Cunard
yes okay now I have a robotic shot he's
great shooter oh my god but I have a
problem with this that you're playing a
pickup game at Duke yeah and it felt
like the defense was pretty lacks on you
that it felt like they were giving you a
foul on Randy
locked inside so a guy who's on your
roll is guarding you locking when he
wants to beat me goes a thousand percent
yeah he was angry that day because I was
I was playing pretty well in Lockland
was lugging around an extra weight he
was in a bad mood so I time it was easy
to separate from the locker all I did
was run meet Coach K I didn't see Coach
K but I think I met him maybe years ago
you don't even remember what you've done
I don't know maybe I did maybe I didn't
I like Coach K but that was a pretty
great day there at dufan thank you
how was your jump rouse I was hitting
okay I was passing a lot to Luke Luke
and shoot my god and he can get up there
he's just great yeah great well we had a
neighbor's draught recently we're yeah
so you drive you pick Brady yeah brady
and giselle yeah I mean it's a package
deal Seaton picked Chris Pratt non
affairs remember on a ferris in House
Bunny how great she was on there Greg I
didn't know that's a good call I had no
idea who she was
yeah when I did that my policeman scene
right and all of a sudden I I'm like
this this woman she's really sunny fun
and she had no Larry movies and I knew
she was great oh so what I wanted buddy
she was great she had money his house
he's a nice girl yes very talented very
telling right so who would you pick as a
neighbor
ideal neighbor ah I don't know man I
don't even think about that let's see
yeah I love Nicholson and Brando being
neighbors that was funny
no they were actually neighbors they
were neighbors yeah and I that and Jack
always had had fun with Brando those
guys were just Nicholson - does he tell
you stories yes tells me great stories
but do you tell others those creatures
one day when they're not when I'm not
when it's not exposing okay
is there a Shack Nicholson story you can
tell I think I don't remember something
about Jack's saying that Oh Brando used
to screw with them without letting them
in in in the gate like they shared an
intercom or something up the buzz into a
gate and I think they secured a driveway
a driveway and in the end I think
something about Jackie this is Layton at
night and he buzzed Brando and Brando
kept saying whoo
one who wouldn't bugs evaded Nicholson
was gonna come on alright oh but I was
like you have to I don't know how this I
don't know I don't remember the whole
thing though son did you meet Brandon no
how would have been a good one huh yeah
but you all of a sudden at one point you
go my life has changed like you're
you're hanging out with Jack Nicholson
like you move into a neighborhood like
it that's like when did it change ah 20
20 years ago or something changed but
what was I like I think Henry Winkler
was like that waterway that was a became
friends with Henry Winkler that's when I
started me and my friends are like wow
this is insane that we're getting to
hang out with the guys we worship
growing up really yeah I like that
moment because that was the first movie
I was in
actually water brought it to me you
brought me they brought me luck but also
clear this up yes and happy gilmore yeah
was Keith Oberman cast to be the golf
announcer you put Bern Lundqvist in but
because I thought this is how our
conversation started of being in your
movies the Keith didn't make it to the
film shoot in Vancouver I don't know I
thought maybe I met me you said I met
you somewhere we were the next game the
next game and you said they said hey
same in and you go Danny Danny your boy
yes me oh yeah yeah and I go what what
are you talking about oh that's right
that's right yeah
and then you said I like I'm always here
always that Emily when I call my god
yeah that's good Danny
and then you said you're gonna be a cop
you're going to be Danny man Patrick and
I said okay and then you put me I want
you to another level yeah you didn't and
now you can't walk down the street now I
cannot what if your kids want to be
actresses yeah if they is Mike whatever
that was gonna make them happy I have no
idea I don't I don't want them do I like
having control of their lives now and
like helping them figure out if it's fun
or not but whatever they want to do I'll
be happy as long as they stay a pee off
drugs and and and that's about mr. goofy
Tomo it's a goofy town yeah yeah how
we've done it
you grew up here I don't know I would
have been the same guy yeah it's it's a
but you're not a partier
now would you been apart you I would
have probably lived the same way I did
growing up with that stuff but uh I
don't know I don't know I miss I missed
this other one I just did like a week
store you have a comedy and man when I
was in North Carolina and Oklahoma and
Nashville all that stuff I was like man
it's nice here I like to smell the grass
mines me growing up I minds me of mooing
women I miss I miss knowing I would I
would love to live there anyways but
everything you getting kind of
sentimental well I'm getting older that
sounded like a Springsteen song you know
that's an intro to my middle I was in
there now slam would you move back to
New York yeah I would like to do that -
I don't know why it's every time I'm
anywhere I'm like I got a liver a mouse
Olson good to see you buddy love you
every time I honestly those quick eight
day tours that mean the guys have been
done every place I'm in I'm like I got
it I got a move here man this was the
greatest down there but you love casting
in going to Hawaii
love that love Hawaii yes but you did 50
first date yes punch-drunk 50 first
dates and I just go let's go with it
with you and I was in our that old place
I was at moments fish house like a month
ago in there worries you build a beer on
Dave Matthews yeah yeah yeah
that was funny Sandman puts me across
from Dave Matthews he's like Danny you
and Dave are gonna be good friends here
I think you get along you did both can
drink and then I went to shake his hand
and I spilled my pint of beer all over
it yeah yeah well yeah a kid nazar he's
good guy
funny got hairy fry guy uh he's Adam
Sandler playing hurt Sandy Wexler's
available on Netflix you can see the
other movies there the do-over
ridiculous six where I play Abe Lincoln
and it kind of sad that when they're
going to have all the people who played
Abe Lincoln like Daniel days always like
I often said my name is in there
played Abe Lincoln that's kind of a good
man you were great Matt all right so we
have a movie role this summer with the
Dennis and my channe there it's gotta be
good you probably have to wear a suit
okay all of you in location will be Long
Island Long Island strong island okay
hang out but seeing that I'm going to be
East Coast all summer maybe we can go to
a Yankee game all right I'll go want you
throw out the first pitch I'd be fine
he's Adam sailing always great to see
you Sam man thanks very much for coming
in excited the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience